thanks for joining us America CeCe's on
the line in Nashville ICC how are you I
deserve what's up I have a question
about retirement my mom left me a nice
little chunk and it said it has
increased I pretend it's not there thank
God she was very smart woman I can't
touch it I'm 55 because she knew my
husband was gambler I'm to the point now
that it's not changing we pay half and
half in bills he makes us twice as much
as me I've had a heart attack a while
back and I'm not sure how long I'll be
alone I want to leave my son definitely
most of it and I'm wondering if I should
leave him any money because I'm scared
it's just gonna be blown at the casino
no you're sure it's gonna be blown at
the casino yeah you're not scared it's
it's a pretty much a sure thing because
this isn't something that's happened 1
or 2 times it's happened a lot over the
years right yep I didn't know he was a
gambler when I married him how long you
guys been married almost 20 years I have
a son that I heard he decided that if
something happens I want to make a well
to where he goes through your program
before he gets any of the money and do
like my mom did leave a monastic but at
this point I don't know if I should help
my husband how old is old is your son 28
and he has two sons that I'd like to
help but my husband and his two sons
don't really believe in God and I don't
know if I could trust them with any
money my son does believe in God he's
not real smart with money but I want to
I'd sort of like to leave his sons Chum
and my son the majority I don't know if
that's right or not there's nothing
there's not a right or a wrong
it's what you want to do it's your money
and so I mean there's not you're not
doing immoral either way I mean you
could look at them and say you know
they're not your kids and your mom the
money that was left to you being left to
your son would not be unusual at all
okay and then what about my 401 K
because I think that my husband is so
irresponsible with money maybe pay off
the house I mean you know 20,000 more
but could you know to where I know he
could live because he also has he can
lose the house huh we can't guarantee
that he can live as long as he has a
gambling problem you can't you could
leave him two million dollars and you
can't guarantee he won't go through it
so would I be wrong of not leaving him
the money and leaving it to my son and a
little child to his you wouldn't be
wrong at all because here's the thing
whatever you leave him has a high
probability of getting wasted that's
what you're telling me right yeah I'm
not even sure if I'm gonna be with him
much longer right now I'm I'm just
scared that if I have another heart
attack before I I don't want him getting
here's the thing here's the thing about
a will a will is not permanent until you
die and so if you want to set a will up
for the way things are right now and
then things get better with your health
or things get better with your marriage
or things get better with some of these
kids and you want to change the will
then you can change the will okay but I
would set a will up now for the way
things are now
and then I begin talking to the
different parties that are involved your
son telling him he needs to get through
Financial Peace University and start
being a grown-up and handling money well
because his grandmother left him an
inheritance that you're going to pass
through to him and you're not going to
do that if he's being irresponsible and
you can call him out your husband you
can say we're gonna have to do something
with this marriage I that this
continuing to live in this gambling mess
is not something I'm gonna do you lose
everything you make and
we can't get ahead because of your
misbehavior and it's a problem for me
and you would get to work on your
marriage and then in the midst of that
maybe you can begin to work with his
sons even and and have some connectivity
there but you know I you need to do
these things from strength going forward
meaning that you're you're kind but
you're firm and you just say this is
this is where I stand on these things
and get yourself some good counseling
with a marriage counselor whether he'll
go or not to start to give you some
input on how to deal with some of these
things because this probably has
something to do with the stress which
might have something today with a heart
attack well yeah the heart attack
definitely was from the stress and he
still wants to put more stress on me and
I'm just I'm to the point I'm ready to
walk away and I know in God's eyes
divorce isn't always easy this is where
you need to get some counsel from a
pastor and you need to sit down and get
some marriage counseling I brought that
up the last thing I said was you need a
marriage counseling that's all that work
and he told me for everything you've
been through you go first and then I'll
go through and I'm just okay and that's
the cop oh that's okay go
but the thing is I don't think he'll
ever go well it doesn't then you can
make your decision but you need someone
to guide you more than some guy on the
radio for three minutes okay on
something is important there's a 20-year
marriage and so are you are you
affiliated with a good church I am that
they don't have counseling through there
I guess but I will call them and ask
them who they recommend I have and they
don't actually know okay well hold on
Kelly I'll get your recommendation all
right thank you
okay we'll get your recommendation for a
good marriage counselor in the Nashville
area one thing yeah oh yeah we a lot so
much and God bless you for teaching
people about money you too darlin we
appreciate you calling in and just get
some help and get somebody to walk with
you and some help meaning just somebody
to coach you they can hear that all the
details of this and can confirm your
decisions and the the speed of your
decisions you don't want to make them
out of fear or out of anger or out of
hurt
you want to make decisions that are
based on wisdom
and sometimes they're still hard
decisions sometimes they're still
boundaries that have to be put up I mean
if the stress is affecting your health
at this level there may be some things
you have to do that are that are hard
hard decisions after 20 years I hope
that isn't what happens but sometimes
when a guy or a gal is like your husband
is put with put forth with a the
situation that you are actually leaving
if this doesn't change then sometimes
things change they don't always but
sometimes they do so if you especially
if you do it properly so I think you
jump in there and get some guidance and
that'll help you you know help you with
some of these other decisions then but
there's nothing wrong with doing a will
now and doing a different one a year
from now based on new circumstances at
that point
hold on Kelly I'll pick up and we'll get
you some help
you